[Music]
all right let's take the next call let's
go to
jamie in atlanta hey jamie what's up
hey how are you doing rocking onto the
break of dawn how are you
i'm doing all right um i'll try to
get to the point of my question it's
kind of a long one um
i feel like i'm probably dealing with
some postpartum depression
and anxiety and my husband's a
firefighter
paramedic but he works 24-hour shifts
and is gone
um does it every three days so i'm kind
of left with
the two kids um and
sometimes i feel like i've just kind of
silently been struggling with it i
haven't really wanted to talk to him
about it because
you know he deals with a lot of stuff
too um
our kids have been constantly sick for
like two months
we're talking you know going to urgent
care at least once a week it feels like
going to the doctor so things like that
so a lot of that's kind of fallen on me
and it's not like it's his fault or
anything like that it's just
it just more so falls on me um
and then here recently he ran a very
traumatic call
that hit very close to hose and just as
i kind of felt like i was ready to talk
about how i was
kind of drowning you know at home with
the kids he goes through this
and you know i he was always pretty good
about
you know tough calls he can kind of put
it in the back seat if you will he
followed away
hey jamie talk directly into your
mouthpiece for me oh i'm sorry
i'm sorry perfect um and then this
i'm sorry um and then this call he just
lost it and cried um
i can literally count probably on one
hand the times that i've seen you know
my husband cry
yeah so i didn't know what to do
um don't be don't you don't have to be
you know what the beaker
is but what was it uh a person down call
okay okay yeah um so
and i want to give away too many details
that's great it's just very
yeah so when you say that you think you
are
struggling from postpartum what makes
you think that because you pain
here's the deal you may very well be you
just painted me a picture
of a totally normal
completely fried and exhausted mom
and wife of a first responder
which is very very lonely
and very exhausting and then you throw
in the pandemic and and
and and and er trips and i'm cooked
so all of that if you're at a point
where you
feel like you were standing over the
precipice of a big giant hole i would
tell you
exactly where you need to be like that
makes sense to me um
but you may also have postpartum on top
of this tell me about that
well i mean my baby was born in the
height
of the pandemic last year um
to the point where i almost didn't have
my husband there for delivery
um so he's he's a year old now so
i mean i don't know if it still could be
postpartum i know he's you know they say
it's usually like birth to a year
old um but it's i mean i don't know it's
just
just some days i listen to another
podcast
girl saying like sometimes you just
don't even like your kids and that's
kind of where i feel like
i'm at because they're so ex it's just
so exhausting
to have everything just come at you you
know left and right
i know a lot of people my age who don't
like their kids
they love them but there's just seasons
where it's like whoa
um can you please stay well you know
yes all right here's what i want to do i
just want to get up and go to the
bathroom
in a room alone and not have a trail of
little ducklings be like mom hey mom
mom or just scream right back so
they follow you oh my gosh yes
everywhere and that's
this is me projecting on to being a
new mom i don't know what that's like i
know when i just get home they follow me
around and it's like two hours a day
much less
right so um so here's the thing
i i don't know if i've got more personal
experience
slash professional experience in this
one issue this one thing
than what i'm going to describe to you
right now okay
when you are married to somebody when
you're in a relationship with somebody
and
you are struggling and they
have a profession whether it's a doctor
a lawyer a preacher
a first responder a cop the
an hr director these day a teacher
and you know they are going through hard
things
what makes sense logically
is that i'm gonna shield my stuff from
them
because i know they're having a hard
time and i don't want to burden them
with
my stuff because they're having a hard
time and so what happens is
and this is this happens all the time
spouses end up drowning because they
don't want to wave their hand in the air
and let somebody know that they're
they can't touch and they're in the
water right
and here's what happens the spouse is
also drowning
because it's not about the um
it's not about the shared burden issue
it's about the connection issue
and so when you see a first responder
get home and they just collapse in tears
and you go whoa it's easy to see that as
oh they're carrying so much trauma
seeing so much trauma
that i can't tell them that i'm drowning
too
and what i would suggest is they are
they the cure for trauma is connection
and so there's a difference between
using each other as
dumpsters right as trash bins you're not
going to believe what happened today
yeah and there is something really
valuable
about saying i am really hurting how are
you
right not that you're going to solve
each other's problems and what first
responders especially firemen ems and
cops
they get home i say that doctors and
lawyers do it too they get home
and then wife you know i'm just
generalizing this
wife says hey billy and tommy were the
worst today
well you're not asking for what to how
to solve that
you're just trying to connect with
somebody and they respond with well you
should have done this and this and
right in the because they know how to
solve problems that's what they do all
day
and then you end up further apart than
you started right
yeah so here's what i hear i hear two
people
desperate to reconnect
two little kids will drive a wedge in
the tightest of relationships just
because two little kids crap everywhere
and they yell all the time they don't
sleep right
and taking kids in and out of the er
all by yourself is a wedge between two
people i don't care how tight you are
and dealing with death and
regimen and burning homes and car wrecks
after another after another
that'll drive a wedge between people and
so
when you've got little kids you have to
be hyper intentional
about connection when you work a job
where you are
dealing with secondary traumatic stress
other people's drama other people's
trauma for a living
you got to be hyper intentional about
connection here's what that looks like
in real time okay jamie
it looks like him coming home and not
telling you
about blood and guts that's not it
it's him coming home and having 10
minutes to hold your hands and look you
in the eye and say
whoo i saw some stuff that i shouldn't
have seen today really hard
and you holding him looking him in the
eye saying
tell me about how that feels in your
body and him being able to say
i don't know if i can breathe and him
being able to
cycle through that experience with you
not with blood and guts not oh my gosh
my boss
but hey i s like man i really had a hard
day at work my boss said some stuff that
got in my soul
and then instead of you going well you
should have said this and you say
hey tell me where that's showing up in
your body how does that feel
in him going to my guts right or it's in
my chest i can't breathe
whatever that feels like and then you
being able to say and being able to look
at you and go
you look like you got hit by a bus
you're still beautiful and pretty but
whoa you look like you're carrying a lot
and you say
yeah um today was a really hard day with
the kids it was hard
and you being able to talk about what
your experience was not and then
and then oh my gosh and there was poop
and but it's just being able to say it
was so hard
right and so you're looking at places
you can have connection
and so here's what i'll tell you here's
how i've seen it happen here's how i've
done it and i haven't
i've done it terrible in my house like
what you're explaining to me
i've been through in my home okay
this is hard very quickly
the i don't want to talk to him about it
because i don't want to burden him
you know what that becomes a secret
i'm just going to hold on to this and
then very quickly that secret becomes
are you doing all right yeah i'm fine
and you know what that is that's a lie
it's not true
and now all of a sudden i've got
deception between me and my wife
and then that's kind of where i'm at
yeah and so you know what's gonna happen
here
is you're gonna find yourself mad that
you're having to lie
and you're going to blame him for that
madness
and then i don't care who you are i
don't care what situation
you will find connections somewhere else
period
our brains are it's too it drives every
function of our bodies
our heart rates our brains it it drives
everything
and you might find connection through
gardening or making a list
or find connection through some social
causes or your church or
you will find it somewhere else that's
also where you
find it with another drink and another
drink or a drink
or some guy who is picking up their kid
and just says man you are awesome right
and suddenly it's like oh i haven't had
anybody tell me i'm awesome
right it happened so in inconspicuously
right and so and happens vice versa here
on the other side too
double back down on that connection
right
this is one of those moments where we
have i feel like am i reading your mail
here
kind of yeah you're getting quieter and
quieter i know i'm talking a lot
no no so
here's what i've got as i'm telling you
you're and i'm telling everybody
listening
you don't protect the person you love by
shutting them off
you don't protect the person you love by
keeping secrets you do protect them by
the details
by the blood and the guts right and the
color of poop on your shirt
that's not always helpful right um
you don't protect them by keeping
secrets and secrets just
end in ash every time or they
end in 40 year olds roommates
right where you have separate parallel
lives so here's the thing
find a babysitter find one of his 24
cycles off
and i want you all to go out to
breakfast somewhere together
and just exhale and tell him hey i miss
you
and i know you miss me and we are
starting to drift
and we're going to do whatever it takes
to double back and it's probably going
to mean you all need to go see a
marriage counselor not because your
marriage is in jeopardy although it
might be i don't know
but you're probably going to need to go
see somebody to learn some tools
and first responders are the best
at first responding they are not always
the best at learning
how to connect relationally because they
have to disconnect that part of their
brain to respond to blood and guts every
night every night every night
but that sort of response doesn't work
inside a home
so go talk to a counselor go talk to a
pastor but look your husband
and say hey i feel like we're drifting
and we're not gonna do this
because you mean everything to me and
he's gonna look at you and say you mean
everything to me
and we're gonna double down on
reconnecting what i promise you
jamie i promise you if you make
reconnection your priority it'll send
you both on a journey
but man your marriage will be stronger
and more incredible
you got it you've heard me say this a
million times you got to clear the deck
you got to burn
not burn but you got to sweep excavate
all of the old building out
you got two kids you're exhausted
you got to build something new build it
intentionally together and then man
that foundation is so strong ain't
nothing gonna shake that
that's a lie something will shake it big
time and then you may have to
knock it down and rebuild something else
but you're gonna keep doing it together
and together because you're doubling
down on that connection
and back to the postpartum if you
are worried that you are thinking about
hurting yourself worry about hurting
somebody else
you are going for days on end without
sleeping you are going for days on end
with
that rattling in your bones call your
doctor don't hesitate to do it
right postpartum is real it's terrifying
it is disconnecting for everybody call
your doctor
if you're worried about postpartum okay
thank you so much for your call jamie
oh man what a blessing appreciate you so
much